Plays a circuit.
So there's a guy named Jaak,
Panksepp,
who I would roundly recommend that
you read if you're interested in in
behavioral neuroscience.
I think he's a genius.
He's sort of on par with
gray as far as I'm concerned.
And on par with Swanson and peg,
except I believe discovered
the play circuit in mammals.
And so,
you know,
two thumbs up for him.
That's a big deal.
That's kind of like discovering
a continent from the
psychological perspective.
And it's a search,
it's a circuit that
separate from exploration,
which is kind of interesting cause you
think about play as a form of exploratory
behavior,
but it's sufficiently different from,
from standard exploratory behavior that
it has a circuit that's devoted to it.
And there's a lot of primary circuits,
you know,
and they're networked in
with the rest of the brain.
And obviously circuit is a,
you know,
a metaphor.
So I could say there's a lot
of primary subpersonalities,
they're like one eyed monster.
There's only one thing thereafter,
you know,
and there's a whole bunch of them.
And so roughly speaking,
they regulate the things I already
mentioned that the hypothalamus regulates
defensive aggression,
sexual behavior,
temperature,
regulation,
food and water intake,
excretion,
while then there's one for breathing,
then there's another for pain,
then there's another for anxiety.
Um,
and there's another for
exploration and there's others.
There's sensory modules as well.
You know,
there's a visual circuit and an auditory
circuit and the olfactory circuit and
the circuit that's devoted to taste and,
and there's a circuit that keeps track
of how your body is localized in space.
That's a parietal circuit.
And um,
what else is important?
Oh yeah.
There's a circuit that you can use to
abstractly model perceptual structures and
patterns of behavior before you
implement them in the world.
And that seems to be a higher
cortical function fundamentally.
And you'd associate that with the
contents of your consciousness.
There's a language circuit,
um,
though.
Oh yeah.
There's an empathy circuit that
mediates maternal behavior.
There's a hunting circuit that
mediates predatory behavior.
There's a circuit to check dominance
and subordinate subordination.
MMM.
There's a circuit that mediates
creativity and human beings.
There's a circuit that
mediates social activity.
So,
and,
and the,
the positive reinforcing
nature of social activity.
And that's quite tightly expo x
associated with the exploratory circuit.
Um,
let's see.
Well that's,
you know,
that's not too bad for the beginning.
I'm sure I've missed some
and I'll remember them.
But,
and each of those subsystems is
important enough so that there's a neuro
architecture devoted to it.
Now some of those neural architectures
are flexible enough so that if they don't
develop one brain area,
they'll develop an another.
So it's,
it's not exactly as if the location
of these functions is specifically
determined in advance before development.
So for example,
if you have a baby and it has,
you know,
epilepsy and the epilepsy is really bad,
sometimes they'll take out the
whole left or right hemisphere.
And if they do that early enough doesn't
really seem to have much consequence
for the baby,
you know,
which is pretty weird.
You think?
Well,
half the brain that problem fairly useful.
But in some sense it's as if the cortical
elements of the brain are territory
that can be inhabited in colonized
by the lower levels of the brain.
And so you could say that the
lower levels of the brain,
including the visual input systems,
would just as soon call a nice,
what we call the visual cortex.
But if there's no visual cortex
because it's being removed,
then they'll just go call tonight
as part of the auditory cortex.
You know,
and what you see in other situations
sometimes is that people have high,
high hydrocephaly.
And what that means is that their
cerebral spinal fluid builds up in their
brain.
And so the ventricles get very enlarged.
And so if you take an x ray or
an MRI or other sort of scan,
if these people,
you'll find that their entire skull is
full of water except for like a half inch
thin slice of cortical
tissue around the water,
like a balloon.
And one of the guys who was like that,
they had a phd in
mathematics from Cambridge,
you know,
5% of his brain tissue is intact.
Now,
it was pretty active that 5% and you
could also be sure that it would not have
been very resilient to damage.